hey friends so i've got kind of a funny
story to tell you all but uh this is
going to be another one of my
illustrious walk-in talks so
let's go for a brief walk around the
neighborhood shall we drex here from
drexfactor poi sharing with you the love
of boy spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and today
i wanted to tell you
a little story from my past because
it has some impact on some things that
are going to happen to me in the future
before we dive in i just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission so it is a
glorious saturday morning here in takoma
park right on the border of washington
dc where i live
we have gotten so much rain lately and
it is
such a relief to have it be so nice out
now so i have definitely dropped several
videos lately
um that have been about big topics uh in
the flow arts and
especially stuff around fire festivals
and taking big swings in terms of uh
making statements about
things happening at the fire festivals
that i would like to see change
and i kind of needed a week to do
something a little bit lighter something
a little bit more chill because um
you know
writing those videos having those
discussions that eats up some spoons and
sometimes
you just want to have a chill week you
know so that end um
this past week my friend vanna aristacat
on instagram
uploaded a really interesting meme where
she was kind of telling
her backstory as a flow artist
i've mentioned before that uh
ironically enough like i get asked this
question all the time of when i started
uh spinning poi
i don't actually know the answer to that
question because um
you know it happens sometime between
burning man 2006 and
uh
my friend's wedding in june of 2007
because i know i spun fire at their
wedding
and in between there i just don't know
because
at the time
i didn't realize that information was
going to turn out to be important
but in watching that video it made me
realize that there is another auspicious
anniversary in my past that i would like
to talk about because
it's actually come up
relatively frequently for me lately
especially in therapy and it is
something that i've been kind of working
on recognizing and accepting about
myself so this takes us all the way back
to when i was a teeny tiny drex of only
five years old
growing up in boulder colorado
and i was in kindergarten
and this was
the what this was the first of many
businesses that i started
as a little kindergartner
uh i
was putting together these uh drawings
of dinosaurs because i loved
dinosaurs
and i got it into my head that i was
gonna sell them for one cent a piece
and
that i was going to give some drawings
away to a few friends for free
in exchange for them
talking my drawings up to the people in
the class and getting them interested in
buying their own so like
at the age of five
i somehow understood the basics of like
advertising and marketing and this still
strikes me as rather precocious
it's also a piece of myself that i kind
of forgot about for many years there's a
lot of reasons for this not the least of
which because there was a person in a
position of authority in my life who
decided to tell a five-year-old child
that their business plan was terrible
and that kind of put me off of it for a
good long time but i did come back
around and it's kind of become an
interesting theme of my life
that
i have been both a very creative person
as well as a creative person that's
always found a way to create sustainable
businesses around the arts that i get
into you know before i graduated from
high school i was getting paid to draw
comic books later on when i got into
music i managed the books for my band
and while we were never the most popular
band in the front range region
we were certainly one of the most
profitable we made money every single
year that we were running and as i've
been able to gather talking with other
bands both before during and after
that's a pretty rare feat and of course
when i took up flow arts i tried several
different business models to try and
make it sustainable for myself
everything from you know teaching
in-person classes to
uh finding ways of making my channel pay
for itself to selling contact poi
you know
every single step of the way i have
found a way to merge together
entrepreneurship and art
and i'm realizing more and more that
that's kind of a rare combination for a
lot of people it's also something that
kind of took me a long time to accept
about myself not just because
there once again were people in
positions of authority around me growing
up who made it seem like a bad thing
that i wanted to start businesses as a
little kid
but also too because we so frequently
think about art and entrepreneurship as
being opposites or as being in
competition with each other
and
in my life at least there's never been a
time when they have been in competition
with each other and don't get me wrong i
do feel for people that do struggle with
those pieces whether it be not wanting
to have to do the terrible work of
marketing one's work or thinking about
how to produce work that is going to be
you know accessible enough that other
people are going to want to pay you for
it
um
i really do feel for people that have
those struggles i'm just not one of them
you know i've always looked at the art
that i produce as not just being
something that is creatively fulfilling
for me
but also as being something that can
fulfill a need for other people as well
to be perfectly frank that's part of
what i love about it i love seeing the
impact that the work that i produce has
on others
and
you know it's weird because
sometimes it's very lonely working
within that context because i feel like
nobody else gets it on that level
and
you know i can talk with people about
you know tech about dance what have you
but talking with them about kind of
the unique space that you occupy
when you know you are putting together
art and commerce there's a really really
small pool of people for whom that is a
conversation that they're either a
prepared or uh
you know be able to engage with and you
know given how much being anti-corporate
anti-commercial anti-capitalist is
so very integrated into flow culture
right now
it's also something that i
sometimes feel a little you know
shameful about or i'm kind of afraid to
bring up
you know not only is it one of those
things that there's feels like there's
few people i can talk to about it
but also too that the mere idea of
merging together
entrepreneurship and art is something
that sometimes feels like it carries a
certain stigma with it i think a lot of
creative people struggle to kind of
find ways of living authentically of you
know being able to express themselves as
creative individuals in a
culture that very frequently does not
make that very easy and you know i have
that struggle too
but i think also too i've struggled a
bit with recognizing
this particular piece of myself as a
creative individual of recognizing
that you know what
those instincts that drive me to
you know
want to
make a flow arts channel pay for itself
so i can do it full time that you know
want to find ways of getting people
access to things that are going to
improve their lives
that that is a thing that i should also
kind of be proud of and think of as
being as authentic as any of the art
that i produce as well i think a big
part of why that's on my mind lately is
that i'm in the process
of making some pivots in the way that i
look at my position in the flow arts
world and the things that i want to see
existing in the flow arts world the
relationships that i want to see people
cultivating with each other and the ways
that we build our community
these are going to be some pretty big
swings and there's no guarantee that
they're going to land
but
i'm still excited for them
and also a little terrified and i think
that as i'm approaching those big swings
and especially kind of coping with the
fear associated with them
one of those things that it is helpful
for me to remind me about myself
is that this is nothing new
that
you know every step of my life
i have tried to find creative ways to
solve problems sustainably
and that
it's never really been about like
necessarily making money or uh you know
trying to be popular anything like that
more often than not it's just about
wanting to see the things in the world
that i think would make it an awesome
place
and working on solving the problems that
are going to be involved in doing that
and that's something that i should be
proud of
yeah so today i'm taking a breather
reflecting on the past
thinking about how it's going to inform
my future
and giving myself some permission to
recognize that there are some things
that make me special
in this regard and that
not to be afraid of the ways in which
that drives me to keep on making changes
you know so thanks for listening to me
ramble about my history as an
entrepreneur and
how this is going to have an impact on
my future with the flow world too did
you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and of course to help other people
find this video this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
of these wonderful people right here
these are my flow patrons on patreon the
people who have believed in the work
that i'm doing enough to help support it
financially thank you one and all for
your wonderful support as well as the
support of the people listed down in the
description if you're watching and
you're not currently a supporter and you
would like to become a supporter if you
would like to help me out on my mission
of bringing flow arts and poi spinning
to the wider world and helping people
connect with their brains and their
bodies you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorkoi and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and best of all
you will be directly involved in making
sure that i can keep on making these
videos and making the impact that i want
to in the world so go check that out
please and thank you are you interested
in hearing me ramble on more about a
variety of other topics both personal as
well as in the flow arts and sometimes
both at the same time i'm going to go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
some other video blogs that i have done
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on youtube
make sure to get outside i hope it is as
beautiful where you live as it is where
i live right now
uh make sure that you get some flow in
you it's good for your brain and your
body
and i'll see you with new video on
wednesday
peace